stalk we have Williams lobster from iqc
at the University of Waterloo and
William hopefully will decipher for us
the algebraic side of the MIP star
equals re result and the floor is yours
thanks Andrea and thanks to the
organizers for keeping this going and
for the opportunity to speak so what I
want to talk about is well first the
condom bedding problem so if you've seen
a statement for this it's usually stated
something like this does every separable
finite von Neumann algebra in bed in are
you okay and or sometimes called R Omega
and Omega or U is an ultra filter and R
is the hyper finite to one factor and
our U is the ultra power of the hyper
finite to one factor and on the other
hand we have this recent theorem so that
nip star equals re which now I'm sure
everyone in the audience is heard
implies that the con embedding problem
is false and looking at these two these
two statements the theorem if star
equals re and the con embedding problem
I'm not going to say what if star equals
re is but we've been having some talks
and will continue to have talks about it
I guess so I can skip that it probably
seems like these are kind of two
different worlds and these are these
problems really aren't connected at all
and part of the reason the con embedding
problem has become so famous is that
it's not just a problem about embedding
volume and algebra Xin this ultra power
but it has many equivalent formulations
and so the corollary that con embedding
is false because MIT star equals re uses
an equivalence of the con embedding
problem with the what's called
seriousness problem which is really
about the separation between quantum
quantum correlation sets so what I want
to talk about is kind of a
how can we see if these two worlds of
fun diamond algebras and non-local games
are directly connected so we'll see how
successful this is I there is a way to
see that these are directly connected
more than one way really but we'll see
if it fits into 15 minutes also I don't
like giving very technical talks but the
I don't think it would be possible to do
justice to this topic if unless I leave
you with some idea at least of what what
our U is and to do that we do need to
get into some technicalities so I
apologize in advance if it would make it
easier to have the slides and follow
along kind of your leisure moving
backwards and forwards you can download
these slides at elliptic dots base slash
slides slide Simon's 2020 PDF so to
start with I know that we need to say
what von Neumann algebra is eventually
and I know that not everybody works with
algebra so I can't explain the basics of
algebra and the kind of basic concepts
for them in this talk but for people who
have kind of seen them and but maybe
don't work with them every day or
haven't seen that really work with them
in years what I can do is try and jog
your memory so I'm just gonna kind of
quickly mention some basics just to see
if if that helps so when we talk about
an algebra it's a very simple type of
object is just a vector space with a
bilinear multiplication usually and
definitely in this talk we assume that
algebra is our associative so it doesn't
matter what order we do multiplication
in a B times C is the same as a times B
times C and also that algebra is our
univille so there's an element which
acts like an identity element with
multiplication now what are some
examples of algebra as well there's some
matrices or if you want to be a little
more sophisticated you can take a
Hilbert space and look at bounded linear
operators on that Hilbert space and
actually if you want it would be perfect
fine for this top every time I say
algebra just think matrices or B of H
and in fact that's exactly the kind of
spirit we should have for the subject
we're studying as we'll see now just to
think about these examples a little bit
further both of these have an additional
operation which is the conjugate
transpose operation or the taking the
adjoint so this is called a star
operation it's an anti linear
multiplication reversing operation and
an algebra with this type of operation
in addition to its multiplication and
linear structure is called a star
algebra so in this talk I'm just going
to say algebra and I'll basically always
mean unit or associative star algebra
now there's two more basic concepts I
just want to try and jog your memory on
one is homomorphisms okay so
homomorphism is a linear function
between two algebra --nz such that the
operations of the algebra are preserved
and we have kind of three operations if
we're willing to think about the
identity as an operation okay so we have
a multiplication has to be preserved the
star operation has to be preserved and
the identity has to go to the identity
so for an example of an algebra
homomorphism one which we'll use later
we could think about taking n by n
matrices and embedding them in an K by n
K matrices just by taking X 2 X tends to
with the identity that's an example of
an algebra hole morphism preserves
multiplication addition and the star
operation and the identity goes to the
identity and finally the last basic
concept about algebra is that we're
going to be using all over the place is
the idea of quotients and so you don't
need to kind of read through these all
these definitions I'm just going to kind
of point toward some things so the idea
behind quotients is that if we have a
subspace of the algebra which is kind of
presume closed under multiplication not
just inside the subspace but by all
elements of the algebra so if you've got
something in the subspace something in
the algebra then ax X a and also the
star of X also stay inside this so space
that's called the subspace is called an
ideal of the algebra and the quotient
space is also
in algebra with the kind of induced
operation from the algebra a itself and
it's very nice to so ideals they're
really nice to work with because we
don't really need to say necessarily
everything that's in the ideal just like
when we talk about a subspace we can
talk about the subspace spanned by a set
we can talk about the ideal generated by
some set of elements in a so that's just
define to be the smallest ideal actually
containing those elements okay and we
can use this idea of taking the ideal
January to buy a set of elements and
then taking a quotient to make lots of
new algebra is given an algebra a
alright so in particular if we just took
some sequence of elements x1 up to xn
and y1 up to Y N and we want a new
algebra which is like the algebra a but
where X is actually equal to Y I we
could just take the ideal generated by
x1 minus y1 x2 minus y2 and so on and
now when we quotient L by this ideal
we're setting all these elements to 0 ok
and so in this new algebra all x1 will
be equal to y1 x2 equal to y2 and so on
and so we get this new algebra
unfortunately unlike when we say take
the the span of a set of elements to get
a subspace taking an idea we don't have
very good control over what ends up in
the I do because that's end up being a
closed under multiplication and so it's
possible it even for a very small set of
elements x1 up to xn the ideal generated
by those elements could be could be the
whole algebra itself for instance or
very large at least by the way I think I
didn't include the notation for the
ideal generated by x1 up to X n so we
use just kind of round brackets so this
here is the ideal generated by the
elements X 1 minus y 1 and so on and if
this ideal is equal to a then of course
this algebra would just be a mod a 0 so
there's no guarantee that the algebra we
take when we do this or that we get when
we do this will be interesting it might
just be trivial
okay so that's the part designed to jog
your memory and now I want to get into
something which could be familiar maybe
not and that is finally presented
algebra so for me this is where algebra
gets kind of fun okay so we start with
another familiar algebra which is
polynomials and n variables right so
this is an algebra we can multiply
polynomials we can add polynomials we
can multiply by a scalar and there's no
reason really that our polynomials have
to have commutative variables normally
we think of polynomials is having
commutative variables but we could just
define them in exactly the same way but
say that X I and XJ is not necessarily
the same thing as XJ times X I we get a
much larger set but really just kind of
very easy to understand the elements of
this set just as it is to understand the
algebra of polynomials now this isn't a
star algebra so it's not an algebra it's
not a star algebra but we can make a
star algebra version just by formally
adding in the stars of every variable
okay so the star algebra of generated by
non commutative variables x1 up to xn
it's just the polynomial the non
commutative polynomial algebra generated
by x1 up to xn and X 1 star up to xn
star and the star operation does what
you'd think it takes xi2 xin it takes X
I star to X I back again and then we
just extend that in such a way to make
it anti linear and multiplication
reversing now when we start with this
star algebra of non commutative
polynomials we can get a lot of new
examples of algebra by taking quotients
of this algebra so if I just write down
some f1 up to FN and G 1 up to G M I can
take the ideal generator by f1 minus g1
up to FN minus g-m and then I can take
the quotient of the polynomial algebra
by this ideal and we get an algebra
which is denoted C star x1 xn
so that these are the generators and
then kind of mod the relations F 1
equals G 1 up to F M equals GM should be
there and an algebra of this form is
called a finitely presented algebra ok
so this the choice of generators and
polynomials is called a presentation and
it's finite because we've picked only
finitely many variables and finitely
many relations now so finally presented
algebra as an algebra of this form and
it's easy to write down examples even
and pretty easy to write start writing
down interesting examples so we don't
need to go through all of these examples
I put them in here just to give you some
idea that we could really kind of nuts
with this idea this is just kind of the
beginning but let's just take the first
one for instance if we want to talk
about maybe we want to have a variable
which behaves like a unitary so we start
with C star you you will be our single
variable that means we really have
polynomials in two variables U and U
star and then we modify relations which
say that U star U and uu star are equal
to the identity so what we get is an
algebra where the elements are
polynomials and U and U star and
whenever we see u star you or uu star we
can cancel it out so it behaves just
like a unitary inside this algebra and
we can write down all kinds of things
for instance if we want to talk about K
outcome projective measurement right we
can have variables P 1 up to pk write
down relations that say that they're
actually self adjoint projections and
that they're orthogonal
and then they sum to the identity or if
you liked clifford algebra we could
write down the algebra generated by
generators which are self adjoint and
square to the identity and which anti
commute and we can just kind of keep
going with this any type of relation we
have we can write down an algebra for it
now although it's very really fun to to
play with these kind of star algebra is
coming from quotients of polynomial
algebras I
even even among algebra there still a
bias that the algebra we like the most
is matrices they're just kind of the the
first example we see where we have a non
commutative algebra and so it it would
be really nice if we could just put
everything in terms of matrices and so
if we have some algebra what we can do
is look for homomorphisms from the
algebra to the matrices and these are
called representations of the algebra so
it's kind of a way of writing down for
every element of matrix such that when
we multiply the matrices for different
elements together it would be like we
multiplied the elements of the algebra
together and when we have a finally
presented algebra there's an easy way to
talk about homomorphisms to well to end
in the algebra really so if a is finally
presented then a homomorphism to an
algebra b it's just a couple of elements
in B such that when we plug these into
the relations the relations are
satisfied okay so let's just see that an
example of that let's look at
representation of this algebra of a
single projection which is so a single
variable P self-adjoint and squares to
itself and we're going to look at Home
Office's to be which is the algebra of n
by n matrices okay so it's supposed to
be an element of B for every for every
generator we have only one generator so
it's just an element P in matrices such
that their relations hold when we plug P
into them so we plug this matrix P into
the relations and we see that P has to
satisfy the relations that P star equals
P and that P squared equals B so a
homomorphism from A to B is just a self
adjoint projection in n by n matrices
and that's where I where all these names
come from the algebra of a unitary the
representations of it are just unit Ares
yeah out for the algebra of self adjoint
projection we just saw that the
representations are projections and for
the algebra of a K outcome projective
measurement the representations are K
outcome projective measurements
so maybe this is a good time to pause
just in case somebody wants to type in a
question into the chat I have a question
so when you're taking this homework
homomorphism you were mapping the
elements of a to projections you're
saying right but so a is like the the
algebra of polynomials so you're do I
understand correctly that you're mapping
sort of polynomials in this algebra to
basically polynomials in the projectors
essentially that's right so when you
take a general polynomial in P then you
would map it into the matrices by
plugging in big P for little P so you
would get a polynomial in big P and that
works that's how the recipe for any
finally presented algebra we have some
polynomial in X 1 up to xn and then we
just plug in plug in R be one of the BK
o K should be in here that's important
pardon me so there's a there's a B I for
every X I okay so let's because this
just says yeah well actually I'm a great
question because that's half of that is
my next slide so that's exactly the
question I think we should ask if we
really think that well we want to just
represent everything in terms of
matrices the problem is can we really
see everything inside the algebra a in
terms of matrices this homomorphism
could have a kernel in which case we
might be missing out a lot on a lot of
information from a inside the matrices
and so what we really want to know is
when do we have injective
representations when can we think of a
as a subset of B if so I just put this
down in case people haven't seen it
before if we have an injective
homomorphism of A to B we say that a
embeds in B so what we really want to
know is what algebra is a embed into
matrices special name for these are
called matrix algebra and it's pretty
easy to see if you embed in the matrices
it's a finite dimensional vector space
so you'd have to be a finite dimensional
that
space as well and you can go backwards
so a is a matrix algebra if and only if
a is finite dimensional so not quite the
same thing as being an isomorphism the
only things so there's not many algebra
that are isomorphic to the matrices that
let's say not many finitely presented
algebra so the question then is every
algebra of matrix algebra and it's easy
to find non finite dimensional electric
currents so I'll just skip back to my
examples here these last three examples
actually all happen to be finite
dimensional they're you know kind of
special in that regard but this first
one this this unitary arbitrary powers
of it don't have to vanish so we could
just talk about u u1 u squared u cubed
and so on so this algebra is is infinite
dimensional so it's not a matrix algebra
so thinking about this we might think
well it's nice that we could we we would
be nice if we could think of all algebra
as matrix algebra and we'd never have to
think about anything except matrices but
clearly that's way too strong we can't
use matrices to understand the algebra
in general but people were surprisingly
resistant to give up this idea and so
they thought well maybe we should modify
this and this is where we can it
actually helps to think as the computer
scientists or or physicists I think we
can oh if we think kind of operationally
we can only work with finitely many
elements at any of a at any given time
so let's modify the definition we don't
really care about whether the the kernel
is non-trivial in some specific
representation what we just care about
is for the given set of elements we're
working with are all of them separated
by the representation so in algebra a is
said to be residually finite dimensional
if for every finite subset of a there is
a homomorphism to the matrices such that
Phi X is not equal to Phii for all x and
y and F right so it would be injective
and who was for all X and not equal to Y
in a but we just look at this finite
subset F and ask that
we separate pairs on that finite subset
and the idea is that you could be
residually finite dimensional the N it
might depend on what such that f you
pick here so the larger f you pick or
the kind of maybe the larger degree of
polynomials that you pick an F if this
is a finally presented algebra maybe the
larger n has to be to actually do the
separation but for any finite set you
can find some homomorphism like this
unfortunately this idea doesn't work
either in the sense of could we use this
to understand all algebra so since there
are non RFD algebras so but maybe we're
not ready to give up ok and again we
should now think like physicists maybe
we are willing to tolerate some noise in
our representation maybe it doesn't
matter if the multiplication is exact so
maybe when we multiply two matrices
together it's fine and if it's just
close to what it was supposed to be okay
so we can define a notion of what's
called an epsilon representation it's
easiest to define this for finally
presented algebra so let's say we have a
finally presented algebra and then an
epsilon representation well remember a
representation would be a couple B 1 F 2
B n such that f i-b want to be n is
equal to G I do you want up to be n so
now we'll say an epsilon representation
is a tuple where the difference between
these two matrices is small in some norm
so we can just pick our favorite norm
for this definition we get different
notions of epsilon and representation
for different norms but my favorite norm
is this little Hilbert Schmidt norm so
we'll pick that okay so that's where we
take the trace of a star a and then
divide by the dimension of the space if
we have an N by n matrix and take the
square root the point of this
normalization we can think about that is
if we plug in the identity matrix in
here the trace of the identity is n so
then the little Hilbert Schmidt norm
gives us 1 for the norm of the identity
any questions about the definition of
yeah it is presentation dependent yes
the question is is it presentation
dependent and
is but what will happen is that if we
only care about epsilon asymptotically
then if we change the presentation
there'll be epsilon representations of
course of one presentation will
correspond to oaep salam representations
of another representation
okay so what we really need to do then
is say can we use epsilon
representations to understand algebra is
in general but we've been interrupted we
should talk about like does it really
make sense to talk about these epsilon
representations and maybe a good way to
answer that would be to see if they come
up in any applications it turns out they
do come up in non-local games lucky for
us you know something very connected to
this this workshop how could that have
happened
okay so I want to talk about a specific
type of non-local game so this comes
from Helton Meyer Paulson and Satriano
okay so so remember with a non-local
game I'm going to since I have to go
through all this algebra stuff I'm going
to assume that you can get what a
non-local game is from some of the other
talks if you're not familiar with it but
it can be given by very simply in terms
of input and output sets which for
simplicity I'll assume are the same for
both players and a winning predicate
which given the outputs and the inputs
says whether the players win or lose
usually we include a probability
distribution on inputs here but I only
want to think about perfect strategies
and it doesn't really matter what the
input distribution is so I'm not going
to worry about that now the definition
of of helton admire Paulson and Satriano
is it a non-local game is synchronous if
whenever Alice and Bob received the same
inputs in this game then they win if and
only if their outputs are the same so if
they get the same inputs they have to
output the same outputs and if they do
they win and for synchronous games we
can actually write down a spectral
algebra so it is the algebra generated
by variables so talk about star
polynomials in these variables MX a for
X in inputs and a and the outputs and we
want these MX days to be the projectors
in a measurement that the players will
do on input X ok so the variables have
to sum to 1 over a and the variable
should be projections and also we put in
this condition
that if they lose on inputs X&Y and
outputs a and B then we want the product
of these projections MX a and my B to be
0 so here's this this algebra and it's a
theorem that perfect finite dimensional
strategies Forge for the game correspond
to finite dimensional representations of
this algebra so correspond here means
you have to kind of motto by let's say
non degenerate strategies you don't want
your strategy to have this block of the
matrix outside of the support of the
state you have to get rid of all that
stuff if you do then you get a
correspondence between strategies and
representations now how do
Absalon representations enter into the
picture here well we might say I think
this would be the the way to tackle it
what would happen if we were just to
take one of these finite dimensional
representations and modify it a little
bit so it wasn't exactly a
representation anymore just an epsilon
representation and then we could trace
through the construction of the finite
dimensional strategy and find out that
what we got was a strategy which was
close to perfect that should seem pretty
intuitive and actually it turns out that
there's a correspondence between Epsilon
representations of the algebra and
perfect strategies for the game this
hasn't been written down anywhere that
I'm aware of in exactly this
quantitative form but tamanna' I wrote
it down for linear system games and I
think the same proof should go through
so I'll say this is just say to be kind
of safe this statement is formally
speaking the conjecture based on that
result for linear system games but it
says that if we start with an epsilon
representation then we can get a kind of
a poly epsilon perfect strategy for G
and vice versa
giving given a close to perfect strategy
for the game we can turn it into an
epsilon representation okay so it's a
good time for questions as well yeah
since there's always a true
presentation zero in the fear of does it
mean corresponds to finite dimension
non-trivial representations in some way
yes I got a trick to get out of that oh
I'm hearing myself on your speakers
where do we define homomorphism uh
homework assumes have to send the
identity to the identity so that rules
out the zero homomorphism so there isn't
always a trivial homomorphism if if you
don't you know if you take a slightly
different set of definitions and you
have to come up with some other way to
rule out the the trivial representations
they don't give you a strategy as you
correctly guessed right they don't have
to be an embedding just any
representation at all and that will be
significant later on when we talk about
this con picture okay okay so that was
our interruption about non the whole
game so hopefully it kind of illustrates
this now it is natural to think about
Epsilon representations of an algebra so
here was our definition again of what an
epsilon representation was let's go into
this question about whether we can are
kind of version of a proximate sorry of
residual so we had finite dimensional
and then residual finite dimensional
then we should have what does it mean to
be kind of captured by approximate
representations so I don't know a
standard term for this kind of just
mashed together some some terms that are
from special cases
so we'll say a is a proximal by a matrix
algebra if for every finite subset of
the algebra there is an epsilon
representation of a right which is just
given by a couple such that for every
pair of elements non equal elements in F
they evaluate two different things
on on this tuple now this is the idea of
what we
do-right this would make sense this kind
of matches our F deenis that for every
so RFD would be for every finite subset
there's a representation especially this
is true but for technical reasons we
have to kind of modify this there's a
bunch of things in here that don't make
sense first one is what should we set
epsilon to you don't have a natural
cutoff to know what's interesting for
epsilon well we can get around that
easily enough maybe we want to just say
it's for every epsilon so maybe the the
dimension of this epsilon representation
will have to grow based on the size of
this finite set and epsilon is epsilon
gets smaller and smaller the dimension
of the epsilon representation will grow
but there's a second problem
unfortunately which is that like if we
consider f1 and g1 they're supposed to
be equal in the algebra but all we're
guaranteed is that these two things are
close together in the epsilon
representation they're not necessarily
equal so it doesn't necessarily make
sense to just plug in b1 to BN into an
element of the algebra so what we have
to do is actually take a finite subset
of polynomials and then say that maybe
these two are not equal if for all
polynomials which gives different
elements in the algebra if the
polynomials give different the same
algebra element of the algebra then
they'll be closed
based on the smaller epsilon is the
closer lo get okay so that wouldn't
really kind of capture the right idea so
we want to do this for all polynomials
where F is not equal to G and a and
there's one final problem which I just
came up in in describing why we want to
do this with F not equal to G and a
which is also just saying that F is not
equal to G doesn't really seem like a
very good guarantee especially if like
we're thinking of epsilon is kind of
some noise level noise threshold if they
are bounded by if they're actually like
not equal but within this noise
threshold they wouldn't really wouldn't
really think of them as being different
up to this this noise threshold so to
fix that whoops there we go okay what
we're going to need to add is something
that would be like a bounded gap that
doesn't change with Epsilon
so we'll say a is a
by matrix algebra if there is some
function on the algebra which is zero if
and only if a is equal to zero and then
this is the meaningful part here okay so
for every epsilon and every finite
subset there is an epsilon
representation so such that the
difference between these two elements of
the finite subset F is greater than
Delta F minus G so if F minus G are
equal in the algebra a then there's no
requirement here this just has to be
greater than equal to zero but if this
if F minus GE are different in a then
they have to be bounded below by
something which is independent of
Epsilon now I should say technical note
if the BIS can grow arbitrarily large in
epsilon representations this may not be
a good definition even with all these
technical fixes we put in okay any
questions about this definition um quite
a lot to take in really but the idea
that I hope is clear which is that we
will just want better and better
representation so taking epsilon smaller
and smaller while keeping a finite set
of elements kind of separated apart in
these epsilon representations okay well
looking at this definition its big and
when we think about the definition of
what it meant to be of matrix algebra
that was the snappy definition it was if
and only if a embeds in the matrices
residual finite dimensionality and
especially this approximable by matrix
algebra is not such a snappy definition
so I think it makes sense to look at
that and say can we fix this
and we can we can if we talk about the
notion of a product of algebra that's
just you take the product set so the
elements of it are just sequences of
elements of your algebra say I okay then
you just apply your algebra operations
component wise to that sequence then you
can say that an algebra is RFD if and
only if a embeds in a product of matrix
algebra that's a snappy definition it's
a mass of algebra over here so this
isn't like a functional it's not
very easy to tell us something embeds in
a arbitrary product of matrix algebra
but at least the definition is snappy
okay and we might like to say well can
we do the same thing for a proximal by
matrix algebra so what should we put in
in this place of you know approximable I
matrix algebra so if and only if a
embeds in what and so we can think about
maybe it's helpful just to think about
what this this RFD idea does okay so why
if a is residually finite dimensional
what product does it embed and the idea
is that we have all these homomorphisms
to two matrix algebra 1 for every finite
subset of a so just take the product
across finite subsets of a and for each
one take the the whole morphism for each
component take the homomorphism into the
matrix algebra for that finite subset so
for a proximal 1 matrix calculus we
might like to do the same thing we will
start with the product of matrix algebra
and the idea is maybe we could choose
some sequence of finite sets such that
the union of all these finite sets is
dense in the polynomials just in the
usual way like for every polynomial we
can get something a polynomial whose
coefficients are all close to the
polynomial of the coefficients of the
polynomial we started with right maybe
we could look at like polynomials with
rational coefficients and then just look
at some kind of like increasing a degree
and bound like we could make the the
sequence be polynomials with bounded
degree and also size of numerator and
denominator in the coefficients ok so
then for each one of these yeah just the
question so then here this index set I
is basically the set of all subsets is
that yeah right I kind of like was
hoping this would stay under the rug but
right this could be a really large index
set here technically speaking yeah but
here it's not this has just gone back to
the matrices in its
it's something we kind of get easily
because now we're talking about
approximable and so we can talk about
just dense subset of the algebra and so
we can take like a countable dense
subset kind of simplifies things a
little bit so for each one of these
subsets FK we could map into m and K the
problem is we don't actually have a
homomorphism into n m and K and if we
try and mod out to make it a
homomorphism well modding out a matrix
algebra but like a some arbitrary matrix
really kind of destroys the algebra just
sets it equal to 0 most of the time so
but what we could think about is maybe
we can modify like the elements of this
product are sequences so if we if we
take for every K kind of let's say we're
looking at like X X I and we look at its
image in M and I in the represent the
epsilon representation sorry the let's
say the 1 over K or 1 over I
representation for F I right so that's
what we do for M and I we take a 1 over
high representation of F I so I'm saying
one variable and two different variables
are written on the page it's not my my
best moment there that should be an FK
okay so 1 over K representation for FK
okay well what happens if we plug this
into the defining polynomials for a
we'll see because we're taking 1 over K
representations that the in each
component the polynomials are bounded in
the Hilbert Schmidt norm by 1 over K so
if we look at those the if we look at
this difference here it's bounded in
each component by 1 over K so the
sequence that we get actually goes to 0
that is to say the if we look at what
the poet defining polynomials fi minus G
I go to in this product here when we
plug in this epsilon representation then
we get like an element which is a
sequence of elements and the limit of
that sequence of elements is 0 so what
we can do is we can mod out and set
sequences which go to 0 to 0
in the whole algebra right so we motto
by the ideal this is actually it's not
the ideal generated by but just the
ideal of sequences where the limit of
the elements in the hilbert smith norman
0 ok any questions about this
okay so that's great so we have we have
now a way of giving a snappy definition
of what it means to be approximately by
matrix algebra and there's one thing
that's really annoying about this which
is it's like for some sequence n 1 and 2
and so on we don't really know what
sequence were supposed to plug in there
it was one thing in the RFD case where
well we had the same problem in the RFD
case I should say it's one thing in the
finite dimensional case where it's kind
of like some unknown dimension n so a is
a matrix algebra if and only if it
embeds in m n for some unknown n but
some other thing entirely when we have a
sequence so the question is can we get
rid of this dimension sequenced maybe we
could replace M and I with M infinity
which would be like matrices which are
infinite size but eventually all the
entries go to 0 so then really we have
you know just kind of finite dimensional
matrices at any given point but we don't
have to specify the dimension as long as
we're talking about like a finite subset
of M infinity C and that sounds great it
sounds like it should work perfectly
until we look at the right-hand side
here and we remember that the little
Hilbert Schmidt norm doesn't necessarily
make sense for this M infinity this is
normalized and we don't know what to
normalize by here we can't just divide
by infinity so we need a version of this
where the little Hilbert Schmidt nor
makes sense and the idea behind this is
that we can use our homomorphism from
before where we we embed supposed to put
in what the embedding does here but
let's just walk this through so what we
do is we take MN c and embed it in MN
tensor M - C so just to walk through
what happens in that case we can think
about the little hill where Schmidt norm
on n by n matrices is coming by coming
from the normalized trace so call that
tau n it just takes a trace and then
divides by n and if we take the trace of
the normalized trace of X tense of the
identity where identity is a 2 by 2
matrix here ok then we get
well it's just the same thing as the the
normalize trace of X X which we're
dividing by 2 so it's just the same
thing as a normalized trace we're
dividing by 2 and I should say so what
we get is just the the normalized trace
of X from this so really what we get is
if we take let's say we start with M 2
then we tensor with M 2 again and we
tensor with M 2 again we get a chain of
embeddings the like m2k and then + 2 k
plus 1 and so on where each so each one
of these is it's an algebra homework
morphism it's just X goes to X tensor of
the identity and also it preserves the
normalized trace and has preserves the
Hilbert Schmidt norm so what we can do
is we can think of M 2 as being inside
of M 4 is being inside of M 8 and so on
and then we can think of it as a subset
where the Hilbert Schmidt normal an M 2
comes from the Hoberman normal and 4
which comes from the headsman norm on an
eight and so on so then we can just let
r0 be the union of m2k to the C under
these embeddings and then we can
actually talk about a trace and a helper
Schmidt norm on this r0 and so we can
say that a is approximately matrix
algebra so if then only if a embeds in
sequences in R 0 modulo sequences which
go to 0 so that gives us a snappy that
gives us a snappy version of what it
means to the approximable by matrix
algebra ok we haven't talked at all
about von Oy minorsky star algebra yet
and we need to get to it and to get to
it we need to look back at B of H come
in with a question if you want about
this stuff but otherwise I'll keep
moving so we looked at matrix algebra
algebra which embed in m and C and of
course P of H is a nice generalization
of MNC so it makes sense to also ask
what algebra is in bed in B of H and
from B of H actually from from matrices
as well but we don't really need it as
much there we have an operator norm and
so we can think about that as a norm on
a and it turns out this gives us
way to characterize what algebra is
embed in B of H we can say their algebra
is with a norm satisfying certain
conditions if you want to look at what
the conditions are google presea star
algebra that's what this is uh this is
called it's not a very practical
criterion if you've got some infinite
dimensional algebra asking is given in
terms of a like a finite presentation
you want to figure out if it has a norm
it's not usually very easy and we can do
a little better this isn't much better
but in in some situations it's easier
than figuring out if an algebra has a
norm like this and that's we can ask
whether the algebra has a state so and
then what's used what's called the gns
theorem okay so here's the theorem it
says a state on the algebra can be used
to construct a homomorphism to be of H
which we call the gns representation and
a state is a linear functional a to C
satisfying certain conditions positivity
it's got to be normalized and some
boundedness conditions if we're talking
about general algebra rather than let's
say C star algebra and so sometimes it's
easier to construct a state on a than a
norm so this is sometimes an improvement
sometimes it's not still pretty
difficult now we were asking when is
this when do we have an embedding into B
of H and this really doesn't help too
much with that but we do care about
embedding so there's a term we use if if
this representation is an embedding then
we say that the state is faithful so
faithful state is one where we do get an
embedding and a state is tray shil if it
satisfies the trace property of FA B
equals F ba so we don't need at racial
State to use this gns representation
theorem but trae shal states tend to be
nicer than other states so it's it's
nice to work with them now if we're
working with a sub algebra like an
algebra embedded in B of H then we might
like to a to be closed under limits and
this is getting into what a sea star
algebra no von neumann algebra is so if
the algebra is closed in the operator
norm topology then a is called a sea
star algebra is exactly in algebra which
is closed under taking limits in the
operator norm and
if we have just an arbitrary algebra
embedded in B of H then and we are kind
of want to have an algebra and close
under limits then we can easily get one
we just take the closure in the operator
in ornithology and we get a sea star
algebra containing a it's called this T
star envelope in algebra of a now
sometimes this sea star envelope in
algebra is still too small
so just to see why that is quickly
imagine we had a strictly increasing
chain of closed subspaces in a Hilbert
space H let's say necessarily infinite
dimensional for the sequence to go on
forever and let P I be the orthogonal
projection onto W I okay now if P is the
orthogonal projection onto the union of
this increasing sequence then it's not
true that the P is approached P and the
operator norm
there's always since this you're
straight containment there's always some
vector which is outside the image of P I
but in the sorry outside yeah outside
the image of P I but in the image of P
so so the difference between these two
always has operator norm one however if
we just look at what these operators do
on States then for any pair of states
the limit of P I apply to W inner
product with V will be will approach the
V P W and unfortunately it is possible
to have a c-store algebra where the P is
our an a for all I but P is not an A so
if we're trying to do things with
projections which let's say we do a lot
in quantum information if C star
algebras might be a little too small for
us and so we might prefer to look at
what's called the von Neumann algebra
which is an algebra which contains these
and other limits technically we say it's
closed in the weak operator topology
part of me so given an algebra in B&H we
can talk about it's fun no I'm an
envelope in algebra and it's just the
closure and the weak operator topology
so we can always get one of these and it
has a nice Universal property that if B
is a von Neumann algebra and we have a
homomorphism from A to B
then just like you can extend a
continuous map to the closure of its
domain you could extend this
homomorphism to a home or sysm
homomorphism on the enveloping von
neumann algebra okay so we get a home
morphism from this funnyman algebra to b
which extends the homework is Amane and
what this means is if we're thinking
about embedding problems if we're asking
about embedding into the bondo I'm in
algebra then we might as well take the
von Neumann enveloping algebra of a
because whether or not a embeds into B
is going to be the same as whether the
closure of a into B so thinking about
these ideas about von Neumann algebra
makes sense to go back and look at the
algebra we've seen so far we saw this R
0 which was this Union across matrix
algebra so it preserved the Hilbert
Schmidt norm so I see I am coming up on
time so I think what I'll do
we've got a few more slides to go yet
before we have a natural cutoff spot so
I will go until 455 that's ok
and then stop for questions so what we
get on this algebra we said was we could
actually talk about a trace on this
algebra a normalized trace and that
turns out that traces of State and it's
actually a faithful State so that the
gns representation gives us an embedding
of our 0 and B of H and so we can take
the von Neumann algebra you know closure
of this week an operator closure of this
to get the von Neumann enveloping
algebra and this is exactly what this
unique hyper finite to one factor is so
it's just this algebra that we use to
kind of get rid of having to think about
dimensions now what about this algebra
we took where we took sequences in R 0 n
and mod it out by sequences which go to
0 does this alpha also have a faithful
tration state and the answer is well
there's a possible definition of such a
state maybe we could say that tau tilde
is the limit of tau
to the sequence elements right so the
elements of this algebra AR sequences
and so you say that Cal tilde the
sequence is the limit of tau of this
sequence the problem is this limit in
general most of the time isn't going to
exist and in fact it could just be
unbounded this could go to infinity so
let's try to fix this so first of all we
better take bounded sequences for
technical reasons we take bounded
sequences in the operator norm okay and
when we take bounded sequences this
sequence where we take the traces of
each AI that now has a convergent
subsequence so it would be really nice
we want to take the limit of this but it
might not exist but it has convergent
subsequences so we nice if we could just
choose one of those convergent
subsequences it's a value of the limit
and of course well we could have all
these like oh there could be so many
different convergent subsequences some
of them might even overlap with each
other and in really complicated ways but
maybe um well we have an axiom of choice
it's very helpful for things that
involve choice maybe that can help us to
choose a convergent subsequence and we
can get a definition of a limit where
the limit always exists that seems like
a fairytale but it turns out to be
exactly true so if we pick what's called
a non principal ultra filter on the
natural numbers which these exist
because of the axiom of choice then we
can define what's called an ultra limit
and an ultra limit has the property that
if we take the ultra limit of a sequence
of a bounded sequence of real numbers
then the limit always exists and is
unique so it kind of solves our kind of
a calculus problem of trying to figure
out if the limits exist they always
exist with ultra limits as long as the
sequence is bounded so now we can define
what's called the ultra power of r0 we
take bounded sequences modulo sequences
where the ultra limit is zero and then
for this one we can define the state the
way we want to
by taking tell tilde to be the ultra
limit of tau a is so this is a sequence
of real numbers it's bounded because
these sequences are bounded so the ultra
limit will exist turns out this is a
faithful tration state as well
to get the enveloping von Neumann
algebra we take this are you so we see
that a is a proximal align matrix
algebra if and only if a and beds in are
you so what what algebra is embed in are
you well if we embed an ru ru has a
faithful tray shil state and it it also
is a von Neumann algebra which means we
might as well assume that a is also fine
Norman algebra and so the von Norman
algebra is with faithful traversal
states are exactly that's the definition
of a finite bond alignment algebra so
when we say just every separable finite
von Neumann algebra embedded are you
we're just asking you know are the von
Neumann algebra switch could reasonably
embed in are you do they actually embed
in are you separable here just you can
just think of this as being there to
make sure the von I'm an algebra doesn't
get too big technically speaking
are are you consists of sequences it has
like a bounded cardinality so we can't
make it too big okay so this is a so
we'll cover this slide and then this
will be good place to stop so I
mentioned this connection between
synchronous algebra and and approximate
representations and I left out something
about the connection between perfect
strategies for synchronous games and
synchronous algebra so that is we can
also say when a synchronous game has a
perfect commuting operator strategy and
that's if and only if this algebra has
at racial state to begin with so then
the other thing we said was that near
perfect strategies for apps for
synchronous games correspond to
approximate representations so it turns
out that having a perfect quantum
strategy like a limit of finite
dimensional strategies happens if and
only if the algebra has a homomorphism
to ru exactly by the argument we just
outlined just now we're not worrying
about embeddings anymore on the other
hand because the map star equals re
there is a synchronous non-local game
with the perfect
cqc strategy but no perfect CQA strategy
so that gives us a synchronous game
which has at racial State but no
homomorphisms - are you and then by
doing some kind of just standard
argumentation right so this this algebra
itself isn't a von neumann algebra
necessarily but we can take its image
inside its gns representation and close
it up we get a separable finite volume
in algebra with no homo homomorphisms to
ru so we can think about the MIT star
equals re is giving kind of a strong
counter example to count embedding even
it's in its original formulation and I
say strong here because not only do we
get an algebra which doesn't embed in an
ru but it actually has no homomorphisms
to argue at all so that's a good
stopping point so I guess we take
questions now thank you so are there any
questions you can raise your hand or you
can just write them in the chat you can
start with a longer one so I thought you
might go and say something about if what
kind of strengthening of the map store
equals the result would be interesting
in terms of what are interesting
questions from the fundament algebras
point of view if if if there's a sense
in which the this algebra that you
mentioned on the previous slide that
follows a more result could be made more
concrete or simpler and that would have
that would be an interesting statement
which is just from the mathematical
point of view yes are you asking about
just making a G more concrete or about
making it in a simpler form I guess both
of them so let's say first more concrete
so how non concrete is it right now and
would it be interesting to make it more
concrete what would you expect to learn
then I guess once you've made it more
concrete maybe you can make it simpler
so I wasn't going to the group's
Direction I was just just asking about
robots what are what's interesting there
that might be missing
yes so great question and I think it
depends on first of all you know a
question which you can answer a lot
better than me which is how concrete is
this synchronous non-local game and if
this is can create then the question is
house concrete is the a one so kind of
the two separate questions there and if
we're satisfied that AG is concrete then
the question is just how concrete is a
one and I think you're gonna get
different answers about this from
different people I think it's fair to
say it's a matter of taste for me I like
to see the algebra with the presentation
and how exactly it gets turned into a
von Neumann algebra isn't so interesting
presentation is a lot more interesting
to work with than the von Neumann
algebra so von Neumann algebra is in
general they tend to be pretty hard to
describe all elements of the algebra but
if I was to argue against that then I
would say well very least it would be
better it would be nice to have a
version of this where we would know
something about how much we have to mod
out to get this a 1 when we look at the
image in the gns representation so
especially if we could have an algebra
where the tray shil state was faithful I
think that would be kind of so we could
maybe ask for like a completely you know
a very strong description of the volume
in algebra but maybe that's too much to
ask for because they're just hard to
describe completely in general but I
think it would be fair to say that what
we don't yet have is an idea of how to
get a faithful tray shil State on the
algebra I think my understanding is that
in orcish the presentation is fairly
explicit so so the game is there but the
tration state is less explicit it's not
clear what that racial state is yes
that's a very good point right so
already even right that's right so maybe
we could say step one would be
explicitly described at racial State
even though it's not faithful and step
two is describe the triumph a try and
find an algebra where the state actually
is faithful yeah so yeah so obviously
I'm not proposing solutions to those
just trying to figure out what
the actual problem is so I think if you
have both of those things then then you
would say you had a reasonably concrete
algebra that should really satisfy
anybody anybody
are there any other questions okay then
since it's 2 p.m. let's stop here let's
thank William again for the instructive
table and we continue at 2:15